Stoic, tough, self-reliant, unemotional. Those are some of the watchwords of traditional masculinity, and for some men, they hold powerful sway. The idea that, quote, real men, unquote, exhibit these characteristics, is ingrained in our culture, even after decades of discussing evolving gender roles. Research has long shown that men are less likely than women to seek help or receive treatment for mental health issues.
坚忍、强硬、自立、不动感情。这些是传统男子气概的一些关键词，对某些男人来说，它们具有强大的影响力。即使在讨论演变的性别角色几十年后，认为“真正的男人”（引号引出）表现出这些特征的想法，依然在我们的文化中根深蒂固。长期以来的研究表明，与女性相比，男性更不可能为了心理健康问题寻求帮助或接受治疗。
They are less likely than women to say that they even have close friends, In the United States, men die on average five years earlier than women, and they die by suicide 3.6 times more often. Men commit 90% of all homicides in the U.S., and they make up 77% of homicide victims. What role does traditional masculine ideology play in these disparities, and what can be done to change them? How does traditional masculinity affect men's mental health and physical health? How does it affect women?
与女性相比，他们更不可能说自己甚至有亲密朋友。在美国，男性的平均寿命比女性短五年，而他们自杀的几率是女性的3.6倍。美国所有凶杀案中，90%是由男性犯下的，而他们占凶杀案受害者的77%。传统的男子气概意识形态在这些差异中扮演了什么角色？可以采取什么措施来改变这种状况？传统的男子气概如何影响男性的精神健康和身体健康？它又是如何影响女性的？
Have our ideas of masculinity changed over time, are younger men less tied to traditional masculine ideas than their fathers? And what have psychologists learned about the most effective ways to reach out to men? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Ronald Levant, an emeritus professor of psychology at the University of Ohio in Akron.
我们对男子气概的看法随着时间推移改变了吗？年轻男性是否比他们的父亲更少受传统男子气概观念的束缚？心理学家们对于接触男性的最有效方法了解到了什么？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是俄亥俄州立大学阿克伦分校（University of Ohio in Akron）的心理学荣休教授罗纳德·莱万特（Ronald Levant）博士。
Over his decades-long career, Dr. Levant helped establish the psychology of men and masculinities as a field of study, conducting research on how traditional masculinity ideology shapes men's lives and affects both men and women. He has authored, edited, or co-authored, more than 250 peer-reviewed journal articles, book chapters, and books, including his most recent book, The Tough Standard, The Hard Truths About Masculinity and Violence, published in 2020. He is a fellow of APA and was the 2005 president of the association. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Levant. Thank you, Kim. It's a pleasure to be with you today. Let's start by defining what you mean when you talk about masculinity. In the introduction, I use the term traditional masculine ideology,
在其几十年的职业生涯中，莱万特博士帮助确立了男性与男子气概心理学这一研究领域，并就传统的男子气概意识形态如何塑造男性生活以及如何影响男性和女性展开了研究。他撰写、编辑或联合撰写了250多篇经同行评审的期刊文章、书籍章节和著作，其中包括他于2020年出版的最新著作《严厉的标准：关于男子气概与暴力的残酷真相》（The Tough Standard, The Hard Truths About Masculinity and Violence）。他是美国心理学会（APA）的资深会员，并曾担任该协会2005年的主席。感谢您的到来，莱万特博士。谢谢你，金。很高兴今天能和你在一起。让我们从你谈到男子气概时的定义开始。在介绍中，我使用了传统的男子气概意识形态这个词，
which is a term that you coined. What is traditional masculine ideology? Well, let me back up for a second and just say a few words about how masculinity is understood in our society. In general, Among the public, masculinity is thought to be synonymous with being male. And, you know, it's a fact, if you look it up on various online dictionaries, it's, you know, the qualities of being male, a boy or a man. But psychologists view it in a much more fine-grained way. And we think of masculinity as we do a femininity as essentially gender role.
这是一个你创造的词。什么是传统的男子气概意识形态？好吧，我退回一步，简单说几句我们的社会是如何理解男子气概的。总的来说，在公众当中，男子气概被认为与身为男性是同义词。而且，你知道，这是一个事实，如果你在各种在线词典里查阅它，它就是，你知道的，身为男性、男孩或男人的品质。但心理学家以一种更加细致的方式来看待它。我们将男子气概视为同女性气质一样，本质上是一种性别角色。
roles, roles that are defined by social norms. We're all familiar with social norms. We have norms in different countries for how close you can stand to a person about holding a door for somebody coming behind you. And we also have norms for gender roles. And these norms for boys are expectations for how boys and men should think, feel, and behave. So, when we think of masculinity, we think of it as something that is rather than inherent in the biology of being male, but rather something that is in the culture that's socially constructed, and that consists of a series of social norms.
角色，由社会规范定义的角色。我们都对社会规范很熟悉。我们在不同的国家有关于你可以站在离一个人多近的规范，关于为跟在后面的人扶门的规范。我们也有针对性别角色的规范。这些针对男孩的规范是对男孩和男人应该如何思考、感受和行为的期望。因此，当我们想到男子气概时，我们认为它并不是作为一种身为男性的生物学固有属性，而是存在于文化之中、社会建构的东西，并且它由一系列社会规范组成。
And when we measure traditional masculinity ideology, we measure a set of norms that for boys and men's behavior. There are several scales for measuring traditional masculinity ideology, which I use the abbreviation TMI. The one that I've developed and revised over several decades is called the Male Norms Inventory, and it identifies seven norms, avoiding all things feminine. That's really the predominant norm because masculinity has to be defined as against something, so it's masculinity against femininity. the next norm is restricting the expression of emotions, particularly vulnerable emotions and a caring
当我们衡量传统的男子气概意识形态时，我们是在衡量一组针对男孩和男性行为的规范。有几种用来衡量传统男子气概意识形态的量表，我用缩写TMI来表示。我经过几十年开发和修订的量表被称为“男性规范清单”（Male Norms Inventory），它确定了七个规范，即避免所有女性化的事物。这实际上是最主要的规范，因为男子气概必须通过与某种事物相对立来定义，所以它是男子气概对女性气质。下一个规范是限制情感的表达，尤其是脆弱的情感和关怀
emotions. Next is self-reliance through mechanical skills, toughness, dominance, having a great, placing a great importance on physical sex, and having disdain for sexual minority men, gay and bisexual men. So those are the norms of masculinity. You know, we have been, as I say, developing scales to measure TMI as well as other aspects of masculinity, such as a man's personal conformity to masculine norms, as well as the conflict and stress that a man would experience if he violates those norms. And this has been going on for over four decades. So your most recent book is about the intersection between masculinity and violence. and you argue that most violence, such as gun violence and sexual assault, is committed by men, even though most men are not violent. What role does traditional masculinity ideology play in violent behavior?
情感。接下来是通过技能表现出来的自立、强硬、支配欲、极度重视生理性生活，以及对性少数群体男性（即男同性恋和双性恋男性）的蔑视。这些就是男子气概的规范。你知道，正如我所说，我们一直在开发用于衡量TMI以及男子气概其他方面的量表，例如男性对男子气概规范的个人遵从程度，以及男性在违反这些规范时所经历的冲突和压力。这种情况已经持续了四十多年。因此，你最近的一本新书是关于男子气概与暴力之间的交集的。并且你认为，尽管大多数男性并不暴力，但大多数暴力行为（如枪支暴力和性侵犯）是由男性犯下的。传统的男子气概意识形态在暴力行为中扮演了什么角色？
Well, thank you for that question, and it's really the crux of the matter. I think the paradox that males are responsible for the vast majority of violence, yet the vast majority of males aren't violent, points us to like, okay, can we identify who among the male population is likely to be violent? And you may be aware that some, I think, eight or ten years ago, APA published a report on gun violence. And basically it wound up concluding, I'm going to summarize a very long report briefly, but it said that there are many, many factors that go into it, and there's no one way to really identify it. but the best predictor of future violence is past violence. Exactly.
好的，谢谢你的提问，这确实是问题的关键所在。我认为，男性应对绝大多数暴力负有责任，然而绝大多数男性并不暴力，这一悖论指引我们去思考：好吧，我们能否识别出男性群体中谁更有可能是暴力的？你可能知道，大概在八到十年前，美国心理学会（APA）发布了一份关于枪支暴力的报告。基本上，它最终得出的结论是——我将简要总结一份非常长的报告——但它说，其中涉及非常非常多的因素，并没有单一的方法来真正识别它。但未来暴力行为的最佳预测指标是过去的暴力行为。确实如此。
Well, to me, that begs the question. And I think we should be able to do much better than that. And so as a result of the book that I co-wrote with Shana Pryor, the Tough Standard, we've identified two groups of men who we think account for the linkages with violence. Now, let me just say at the beginning, in psychology, we cannot directly see. study violence. It would be unethical to create an experiment in which violence occurs. So we have to use indirect measures of violence. So we use self-reports of past violence, which, you know, aren't 100% reliable, but it's the best we can do. We use scales to measure aggression or hostility.
好吧，在我看来，这等于是在回避问题。我认为我们本应该做得更好。因此，由于我和沙娜·普赖尔（Shana Pryor）合著的书《严厉的标准》（The Tough Standard），我们确定了两组我们认为与暴力存在关联的男性。现在，请允许我在一开始就说明，在心理学中，我们无法直接观察研究暴力。创建一个发生暴力的实验是不道德的。因此，我们必须使用对暴力的间接测量。所以我们使用对过去暴力的自我报告，你知道，这些报告并非百分之百可靠，但这是我们能做到的最好方法。我们使用量表来衡量攻击性或敌意。
And then we use proxy variables, like inducing a man to punch a punching bag, after in an experiment. So that's as close as we can get. But based on 40 years of studies using, you know, those methods that I describe, and also there are other weaknesses with literature that are true of pretty much all fields of psychology. But based on that, there are really two groups of men that seem to be caused the linkages with hostility, aggression, et cetera, et cetera. One is men who check all the boxes, who score very high on measures of masculinity, whether it's TMI or hypermasculinity or conformity to masculine norms, the men in the upper tail of the distribution.
然后我们使用代理变量，比如在实验后引导男性击打沙袋。所以这就是我们能做到的最接近的方法。但是基于使用我所描述的那些方法进行的为期40年的研究，并且文献也存在其他弱点，这几乎适用于心理学的所有领域，但基于此，确实有两组男性似乎导致了与敌意、攻击性等等的关联。其一是那些符合所有条件、在男子气概测量指标（无论是TMI、超级男子气概还是对男子气概规范的遵从）上得分极高的男性，即分布在分布图上端尾部的男性。
Because masculinity scores tend to be distributed in a rather skewed fashion. I should say that. That the scores are really pushed to the low end. And I'll come back to that point. But there is a thin upper tail of men who we would kind of describe as hypermasculine. And we believe that those, we have not yet found an experiment. There's only one study that supports that. So that finding is a little weak.
因为男子气概的得分往往呈现出相当倾斜的分布方式。我应该这么说。这些得分确实被挤压到了低端。我会回到这一点。但在男性当中有一个薄薄的上端尾巴，我们可以将其描述为超级男子气概。我们相信这些，我们尚未找到一个支持这一点的实验。只有一个研究支持该发现。所以这个发现有点薄弱。
But we think that that is accounts of the linkage. But then there's another group of men, you know, who feel ashamed of themselves for violating masculine norms. Now, I want to back up for a second and say that, Most men, I essentially did a paper looking at three studies conducted over a 17-year period, looking at their scores on the male role norms inventory, my scale. And overall, I found that on average, most men do not endorse traditional masculine norms. But think about it. You know, an adult man likely has a vocational identity.
但我们认为这解释了这种关联。不过还有另一组男性，你知道，他们因为违反了男子气概规范而感到羞耻。现在，我想退回一步说，大多数男性——我基本上做了一篇论文，考察了在17年期间进行的3项研究，观察他们在男性角色规范清单（我的量表）上的得分。总的来说，我发现平均而言，大多数男性并不认同传统的男子气概规范。但想想看。你知道，一个成年男性很可能拥有职业身份。
He likely has an intimate partnership. He may have children. He may have a mortgage or car payments. He's got far too much on his mind to worry about whether he's masculine or not. And most men don't. But there's a minority of men who do, who feel ashamed of themselves for violating masculine norms. I did some studies back in the 90s that showed this very clearly. I had a group of men, and I would pass out three by five index cards and pencils, and I asked them to write their top secret, the thing they've never told anybody and never would tell anybody, down on the paper.
他很可能有亲密的伴侣关系。他可能有孩子。他可能有房贷或车贷。他有太多心事，根本没空去担心自己是否具有男子气概。大多数男人都不会。但确实有一小部分男性会这样，他们因违反男子气概规范而感到羞耻。我在90年代做过一些研究，非常清楚地显示了这一点。我有一群男性，我会分发3乘5的索引卡片和铅笔，我让他们把最高机密、那些他们从未告诉过任何人也绝不会告诉任何人的事情写在纸上。
And then I collected the cards, and I made an elaborate display of shuffling them, and then I started to turn them over and gasp would go up in the room. reason to read them. And what I found was so fascinating that many of the secrets, the shameful secrets that men would never tell anybody, were about violating masculine norms. I backed down from a fight in high school. I had a crush on another boy. I was too close to my mother. As a boy, I cried too often. It almost breaks your heart. These are 40 and 50-year-old men who feel ashamed of themselves for things that are just basically human. So the second thing I learned from that is that it's enormously, it provides enormous relief for men to hear that they are not the only one who have shameful secrets.
然后我收回卡片，做了一个精心洗牌的展示，接着我开始把它们翻过来，房间里就会响起倒吸气声。理由去读它们。我发现的结果如此迷人，许多秘密，那些男性绝不会告诉任何人的羞耻秘密，都是关于违反男子气概规范的。我在高中时退缩了，没有打架。我暗恋另一个男孩。我跟母亲太亲近了。作为一个男孩，我哭得太多了。这几乎让人心碎。这些是40岁和50岁的男性，他们为那些基本上很有人情味的事情感到羞耻。因此，我从中学到的第二件事是，听到自己并不是唯一一个拥有羞耻秘密的人，会给男性带来巨大的宽慰。
Because many men, because they never tell anybody, they never get corrective feedback to the effect that, oh yeah, I felt that way too. Or, oh, yeah, that's normal. And they come out of their inner caves where they think they're the only man in the world has ever violated masculine norms and all those other guys are doing fine. So they've experienced enormous relief from that. But there is this small group of men, like some of the men in this group, who feel ashamed of themselves. And this is called in our field discrepancy strain. It's basically strain the results from a discrepancy between your ideal self-image and your real
因为许多男性，由于从不告诉任何人，他们永远不会得到纠正性的反馈，即“哦，是的，我也曾那样感受过”或“哦，是的，那是正常的”。他们从自己的内洞中走出来，在那里他们认为自己是世界上唯一一个违反过男子气概规范的男人，而其他所有家伙都过得很好。因此，他们从中体验到了巨大的宽慰。但确实存在这样一小群男性，就像这群人中的一些男性一样，他们为自己感到羞耻。在我们的领域，这被称为差异压力（discrepancy strain）。它基本上是由你的理想自我形象与真实自我形象之间的差异所导致的压力。
self-image. That is who you think you should be and who you feel you really. are. And this is very much akin to something well known in our field called cognitive dissidents, which is an unpleasant feeling that people get when they behave in contradiction to their beliefs that drives them to act in a manner consistent with their beliefs. Well, discrepancy strain does the same thing, that when you assess a man for discrepancy saying you will find correlations with measures, indicators of violence. If you experimentally induce discrepancy strain, such has been done in the precarious manhood studies,
也就是你认为自己应该是谁与你觉得自己实际上是谁。这非常类似于我们领域中一个众所周知的概念，叫做认知失调（cognitive dissidents），那是人们在做出违背其信仰的行为时产生的一种令人不快的感觉，它驱使人们以与其信仰一致的方式行事。嗯，差异压力也会产生同样的效果，当你评估一个男性的差异压力时，你会发现它与暴力指标之间存在相关性。如果你通过实验诱发差异压力，正如在岌岌可危的男子气概（precarious manhood）研究中所做的那样，
where you essentially randomly assign men into either an experimental or a control group, and ask the experimental group to do a feminizing task, like braiding the hair on a mannequin and putting pink ribbons in it, versus a masculine. tasks, like tying ropes into knots, and then give both groups of men the choice of sitting quietly in a room or punching a punching bag.
你基本上将男性随机分配到实验组或对照组，并要求实验组完成一项女性化的任务，比如给一个假人编辫子并在上面系粉红色的丝带，而对照组则完成男性化的任务，比如把绳子打成结，然后给两组男性选择：是安静地坐在房间里，还是击打沙袋。
Who do you guess chooses to punch the punching bag more often? The guys with the pink ribbons. Exactly. Because once you threaten their masculinity, they have to demonstrate it. So this particular phenomenon, threatened masculinity, discrepancy strain, precarious manhood, is called by very. various names, is actually found in a wide range of social science literatures, not only in social psychology and counseling psychology, but also in sociology, cultural anthropology, criminology,
你猜谁选择击打沙袋的频率更高？系粉红丝带的那些家伙。没错。因为一旦你威胁到他们的男子气概，他们就必须证明它。因此，这种特定的现象——受到威胁的男子气概、差异压力、岌岌可危的男子气概，有各种各样的称呼——实际上在广泛的社会科学文献中都能找到，不仅在社会心理学和咨询心理学中，也在社会学、文化人类学、犯罪学，
and social work. So, you know, when you find that kind of finding across a range of disciplines, you have to have a lot of confidence in it, and we do. But it even gets better than that. There's a database of school shooters maintained by a psychologist, Peter Langham. And if you go into the database and search for the term masculinity, 18 cases come up. 18 school shooters in the portfolio that is established for them, which includes diaries and medical records and school records and all kinds of information, 18 men have masculinity mentioned.
以及社会工作中。所以，你知道，当你在一系列学科中发现这种发现时，你必须对它充满信心，我们确实如此。但情况甚至比这更好。有一个由心理学家彼得·兰格曼（Peter Langman）维护的学校枪击案数据库。如果你进入数据库搜索“男子气概”一词，就会出现18个案例。在其建立的档案中涉及18名学校枪击案凶手，其中包括日记、医疗记录、学校记录以及各种信息，有18名男性提到了男子气概。
And if you look at those 18 cases, Carefully, what you see in all 18 is threatened masculinity. Boys who are bullied for not being sufficiently masculine. Men who can't get a date with women. You know, just men who, in various ways, feel that they do not measure up, suffer discrepancy strain, feel their masculinity is threatened. I thought, you know, so this connects our, you know, experimental and survey research to anecdotal evidence out there.
如果你仔细观察这18个案例，你在所有18个案例中都能看到受到威胁的男子气概。因为不够具有男子气概而遭到欺凌的男孩。无法与女性约会成功Men的男性。你知道，只是那些在各种方面觉得自己不够标准、遭受差异压力、感到自己的男子气概受到威胁的男性。我想，你知道，所以这把我们的实验和调查研究与现实世界中关于实际枪击案的轶事证据联系在了一起。
in the real world concerning actual gun violence. It's also seen in another anecdotal set of data, which is homicide suicides, that is a person who kills his family and kills himself, or shoots up his workplace and then shoots himself. And also some of the school shooters like Columbine or murder suicides. And in a study of newspaper reports of murder, or suicides. And again, this is anecdotal, found that threatened masculinity played a role in all of the stories they looked at. So clearly, we're linking threatened masculinity, you know, in the experimental and survey research, to real-world evidence, as well as finding it across a range of dissimance. So I really think threatened masculinity is what we have to kind of look at if we are going to
这在另一套轶事数据中也能看到，也就是谋杀自杀案，即一个人杀死家人然后自杀，或者枪击他的工作场所然后自杀。还有一些学校枪击案，比如科伦拜恩（Columbine）或谋杀自杀案。在一项针对谋杀或自杀的新闻报道的研究中。同样，这是轶事，发现受到威胁的男子气概在他们研究的所有故事中都起到了作用。很显然，我们将实验和调查研究中受威胁的男子气概与现实世界的证据联系起来，并在各种差异中发现了它。所以我真的认为，如果要解决我们国家可怕的枪击暴力问题，受威胁的男子气概正是我们必须关注的方面。
solve the horrendous gun violence problem in our country. But how do you get to that before the shooting happens? What is the environment where you're able to test this and then predict a person who is likely to go down that path? Well, you know, I'm a academic psychologist, not a legislator or a public policy person. So I'm weak on the details of how you'd implement this. I mean, we do have scales that you could assess somebody for discrepancy strain. I don't know how you would actually use that information to prevent people from being violent. Do we start testing in schools maybe? I mean, can we identify people when they're young?
但在枪击发生之前，你如何做到这一点呢？在什么样的环境下，你能够测试这一点，并进而预测一个可能会走上这条道路的人呢？好吧，你知道，我是一名学术心理学家，而不是立法者或公共政策制定者。所以在如何实施这一点细节上，我是个弱项。我的意思是，我们确实有可以用来评估某人差异压力的量表。我不知道你将如何实际利用这些信息来阻止人们实施暴力。我们也许开始在学校进行测试吗？我的意思是，我们能在他们年轻时识别出这些人吗？
Well, I think it does go back to intervening when children are young. And what I think the answer is, is that we have to stop. making little boys feel that masculinity is obligatory. That is one of the biggest problems with masculinity is that boys are made to feel that masculinity is obligatory, that they have no choice but to be masculine. They get this primarily from their fathers and from their peers. Even recent research shows that fathers tend to believe that their job
嗯，我认为这确实要追溯到在儿童年幼时进行干预。我认为答案是，我们必须停止让小男孩们觉得男子气概是必须具备的。这是男子气概最大的问题之一，那就是男孩们被迫感到男子气概是强制性的，他们除了具有男子气概别无选择。他们主要从父亲和同龄人那里感受到这一点。甚至最近的研究也表明，父亲往往认为他们的工作是把他们的儿子培养成男人。但是同龄人，正如你非常清楚的那样，在监督男子气概方面是残酷的。
is to make men out of their sons. But the peers, as you well know, are vicious in police. masculinity. Elementary school boys use various epithets, sissy and worse, to refer to these boys, as well as beat them up. So boys are made to feel masculinity is obligatory. Now, contrast that with a family that I saw when I was in practice who basically said, you know, we want to raise our son in a gender-neutral way. We'd like him to have full access to his emotions and not feel that he can't, you know, cry and all this kind of stuff, but we worry about how he's going to be treated out in the world. And I said, you know, that's a very real concern. I think what you need to
小学男生会使用各种绰号，比如“娘娘腔”及更难听的词来指代这些男孩，还会殴打他们。因此，男孩们被迫觉得男子气概是强制性的。现在，将其与我在执业时看到的一个家庭进行对比，他们基本上说：“你知道，我们要以一种性别中立的方式抚养儿子。我们希望他能够充分接触自己的情感，不会觉得不能哭泣等等，但我们担心他在外界会受到怎样的对待。”我说：“你知道，这是一个非常现实的关切。我认为你需要
do is inoculate your son for that eventuality. You can have a conversation with him or several conversations with him along these lines. You know, Johnny, you know, in our house, we think it's okay for boys to cry. But not everybody agrees. And you have to know who, you have to know you're with because sometimes if you're with people who don't agree with you and you cry, they'll get mad at you. And so you have an age-appropriate conversation, but help your son know that there's a time in place. You teach the child display rules.
做的是为你的儿子应对这种可能性做好心理准备。你可以与他进行一次或多次沿着这些思路的对话。你知道，乔尼（Johnny），在我们的家里，我们认为男孩哭泣是可以的。但并不是所有人都同意。你必须知道跟谁在一起，你必须知道你和谁在一起，因为有时如果你和那些不同意你观点的人在一起而你哭了，他们会对你发脾气。因此，你可以进行适合年龄的对话，但要帮助你的儿子知道凡事有时地。你教给孩子展示规则。
And this is a very valuable lesson not only about gender, but teaching a child to discriminate between different groups of people and how they're likely to respond to him. a very useful skill. So that's one way. But as to how we utilize the findings from psychological and social science research to immediately correct the problem, I think we'd have to have to have a panel with some policy experts and legislators to kind of present this information and have them think about what kinds of, you know, social interventions could be done. That's really beyond my level of expertise. Well, let me ask you then following onto what you were just saying, has the public understanding of masculinity changed at all over the decades since you started doing
这不仅是非常有价值的性别一课，而且教会一个孩子去区分不同类型的人以及他们可能对他的反应，这是一项非常实用的技能。所以这是一种方法。但至于我们如何利用心理学和社会科学研究的发现来立即纠正这个问题，我认为我们必须邀请一些政策专家和立法者组成一个小组，来展示这些信息，并让他们思考可以采取什么样的社会干预措施。这确实超出了我的专业水平。好吧，那么接着你刚才所说的话来问你，自从你开始做这项研究以来的几十年里，公众对男子气概的理解发生过任何改变吗？
this research? Do, for example, millennial men believe in these traditional masculine ideas to the same effect that their baby boomer fathers did? No. As a matter of fact, I just published a study in the Sage Journal of Men and Masculinities that actually showed that. What we did is we had a sample of men from young adults, 18 to 30, established adults 30 to 44, middle age, 45 to 60, and 60 plus. And we first did a very sophisticated psychometric analysis called measurement and variance to ensure that each group understood the scales in the same way. And because that's necessary,
例如，千禧一代的男性是否像他们的婴儿潮一代父亲那样相信这些传统的男子气概观念？没有。事实上，我刚刚在《Sage男性与男子气概期刊》（Sage Journal of Men and Masculinities）上发表了一项研究，实际上就显示了这一点。我们所做的是，我们拥有一个男性样本，包括年轻人（18到30岁）、成熟成年人（30到44岁）、中年人（45到60岁）以及60岁以上的人。我们首先进行了一项非常复杂的心理测量分析，称为测量等值性（measurement invariance），以确保每个群体以相同的方式理解这些量表。因为这是必要的，
because not every group will necessarily understand what the scale scores mean in the same way as the other group. So we first established that there was measurement and variance. And then we compared the mean scores on the measure of TMI. I think it was a mail-roll norms inventory short form and the male norms inventory very brief. And we found that the groups that scored the highest were the older groups. So basically, I think what happens is that males wind up living with the masculinity ideology they were raised with.
因为并非每个群体都会必然以与其他群体相同的方式理解量表得分的含义。所以我们首先确立了存在测量等值性。然后我们比较了TMI测量指标上的平均得分。我想那是男性角色规范清单简表和男性规范清单极简表。我们发现得分最高的群体是年长的群体。因此，基本上，我认为发生的情况是，男性最终生活在他们被抚养时所接受的男子气概意识形态中。
And as regards millennials, I think the big difference we've seen is actually goes way beyond measuring masculinity, which is that the norm of disdain for sexual minority men has disappeared. And this is following the over-gaphaffal decision that basically had an enormous impact on the social norms regarding the treatment of GLBTQ people that basically normalized those folks as just human variation rather than the way they were viewed in the 70s in the DSM, diagnostic manual as psychopathological. So I think millennials, along with the rest of society, does not view GLBTQ people as in some way abnormal. The other thing that has changed, and has actually been over the generations, is fathering. In the 1960s,
至于千禧一代，我认为我们看到的巨大差异实际上远远超出了测量男子气概的范畴，那就是对性少数群体男性的蔑视这一规范已经消失了。这紧随奥格费尔判决（over-gaphaffal decision，注：应为Obergefell v. Hodges同性婚姻裁决），该判决基本上对有关对待GLBTQ人群的社会规范产生了巨大影响，基本上将这些人正常化为人类的变异，而不是像他们在70年代的精神疾病诊断与统计手册（DSM）中被视为心理病理学那样。所以我认为千禧一代与社会其他部分一样，并不以某种异常的眼光看待GLBTQ人群。另一个已经改变、且实际上历经数代人发生改变的事情是育儿。在20世纪60年代，
fathers paid did very little care for their children they played with them you know they would do the rough and tumble play but as far as feeding
父亲极少照顾他们的孩子，他们会和他们玩耍，你知道，他们会进行打闹游戏，但至于喂食
diapering waking getting dressed getting fed none of that and when in response to the wife's employment
换尿布、叫醒、穿衣、喂饭，这些全都没有。而为了回应妻子的就业，
men increase their amount of child care a tenth of an hour a day Oh boy, could you spare it? Six measly minutes. Okay, by 1995, the latest time diary study that I know of, and these are very elaborate studies require a lot of funding, which isn't available anymore, found that in households where both parents worked, women did 62% of the family work, which includes child care and housework, and men did 30% of,000. So that's much better than one-tenth of a percent.
男性将他们照顾孩子的时间增加了每天十分之一小时。哦，天哪，你能抽出时间吗？区区六分钟。好吧，到了1995年，据我所知最新的时间日记研究——这些是非常复杂的研究，需要大量资金，而现在已经没有这种资金了——发现在双职工家庭中，女性承担了62%的家庭工作（包括照顾孩子和家务），而男性承担了3万%。所以这比百分之一的十分之一要好得多。
And men had 10 percent more leisure time. So, you know, men are doing more. We've gotten away from this idea called the essential father hypothesis, you know, that dads don't engage in care to the point now that I think we think of fathering as just parenting and parenting doesn't have a gender. and basically we have dads, you know, who provide full care to their children. So a couple of years ago, APA put out a guideline for the psychological treatment of men and boys. That's a project that you started during your APA presidency, and it took quite a long time for us to get that completed.
而且男性的休闲时间多了10%。所以，你知道，男性做得更多了。我们已经摆脱了所谓的“本质父亲假说”（essential father hypothesis），也就是父亲不参与照顾孩子的观点，以至于现在我认为我们把当父亲看作仅仅是父母职责，而父母职责是没有性别的。基本上我们有了为孩子提供全面照顾的父亲。因此，几年前，美国心理学会（APA）发布了一份针对男性和男孩心理治疗的指南。那是你在APA主席任期内启动的一个项目，我们花了相当长的时间才完成它。
Can you talk about why that guideline was necessary and really can you summarize what it says? You're right. It took 13 years from 2005 to 2005 to 2000. As you're aware, Kim, the APA has multiple levels of review for approving guidelines for practice. APA, as you know, is composed of both academics like myself and practitioners. And so we utilize the science created by the academics to specify evidence-based practices for different groups. And we've had guidelines for girls and women, guidelines for older adults, guidelines for GOBTQ folks, guidelines for racial and ethnic minorities, and so on. And when I was president, I set up a commission, a task force to create guidelines for practice
你能谈谈为什么这份指南是必要的，并且真正能总结一下它说了什么吗？你是对的。从2005年到2005年到2000年，花了13年时间。如你所知，金，APA对于批准实践指南有多个级别的审查。如你所知，APA由像我这样的学者和从业人员组成。因此，我们利用学者们创造的科学，来为不同的群体指定基于证据的实践。我们有针对女孩和女性的指南、针对老年人的指南、针对GLBTQ人群的指南、针对种族和少数族裔的指南等等。当我是主席时，我成立了一个委员会、一个工作组来为针对
in boys and men, just because there weren't any, but also because boys and men do not avail themselves of mental health treatment to the extent that girls and women do, largely because of adherence to masculine norms. It is not masculine to ask for help. It is not masculine to express vulnerability. It is not masculine, you know, to not think of themselves as, you know, a hundred percent strong. So men tend, and there's been a lot of studies showing correlations between various masculinity scales and either attitudes or intentions towards seeking help.
男孩和男性的实践制定指南，不仅仅是因为过去没有，也是因为男孩和男性并不像女孩和女性那样积极寻求心理健康治疗，这在很大程度上是因为他们坚持男子气概的规范。寻求帮助不是有男子气概的表现。表达脆弱不是有男子气概的表现。认为自己不是百分之百坚强，不是有男子气概的表现。因此，男性倾向于——并且有很多研究表明各种男子气概量表与对寻求帮助的态度或意向之间存在相关性。
That is, the higher the score in the masculinity scale, the less favorable the attitudes. toward help-seeking or the less they intend to seek help if needed. So we felt, you know, this needed to be looked at. I mean, and we took the big picture. I mean, when you look at psychotherapy, it really began as an enterprise of men treating women with Freud and Breuer in his hysterical patients in Vienna. And it's pretty much continued in that modality until the 70s and after the second wave feminist movement and sort of the feminist scientific movement and Carol Gilligan and, you know, all of these folks in psychology who started revising the canon with regard to gender.
也就是说，男子气概量表上的得分越高，对寻求帮助的态度就越不积极，或者在需要时寻求帮助的意向就越低。因此我们觉得，你知道，有必要对此进行研究。我的意思是，我们采取了宏观视角。我的意思是，当你审视心理 psychotherapy 时，它实际上是作为弗洛伊德和布洛尔在维也纳治疗患歇斯底里症的女性患者的事业开始的。这种情况在很大程度上一直延续到70年代，以及第二波女权主义运动、女权主义科学运动、卡罗尔·吉利根（Carol Gilligan）以及心理学界所有这些开始修改性别正统观念的人出现之后。
And some of us, I was a clinician and others who were clinicians, started experimenting with new methods to engage and treatment. One of the things that I ran up against is the fact that many of your listeners may be aware of is a lot of men have a lot of trouble identifying and describing how they're feeling. They cannot give a good account of their emotional life. Sometimes you've asked them how they're feeling, they'll tell you what they're thinking, or they'll tell you what they're going to do. And there's a word for this.
我们中的一些人——我是一名临床医生，其他也是临床医生的人——开始尝试新的方法来让人们参与治疗。我遇到的事情之一是许多听众可能意识到的事实，即许多男性在识别和描述自己的感受方面遇到了很大困难。他们无法很好地描述自己的情感生活。有时你问他们感觉如何，他们会告诉你他们在想什么，或者他们会告诉你他们将要做什么。这个词有一个专门的称呼。
I hope it won't turn off your listeners. is it's a lexathymia, A-L-E-X-I-T-H-Y-A. It's a Greco-Roman roots, which means without words for emotions. And in my research, I found that there was evidence that as a result of gender role socialization, that boys between Neonese and 6 were socialized to restrict the expression of motions. It may be of interest to you that neonates, as neonates, boys are more emotionally expressive than girls. But what do neonates do? They cry or they sleep.
我希望这不会把你的听众吓跑，它是述情障碍（alexithymia），A-L-E-X-I-T-H-Y-A。它有希腊罗马词根，意思是“没有表达情绪的词汇”。在我的研究中，我发现有证据表明，由于性别角色社会化，介于新生儿和6岁之间的男孩被社会化为限制情感的表达。你可能会感兴趣的是，新生儿，作为新生儿，男孩比女孩更具情绪表达能力。但新生儿会做什么？他们哭或者睡觉。
But this difference holds up until at least one year of age, boys, and they do a lot more one year of age than they do hours after birth. But the difference starts to reverse itself by two, where girls are more emotionally verbally, more verbally emotionally expressive than boys. and between four and six, little boys lose their facial expressivity. Now, what's happening to boys between four and six? They're in preschool or elementary school, and they're getting police by other boys. They're basically other boys are shaming them for expressing emotions.
但这种差异一直持续到至少一岁大，男孩们在满一岁时的表现比出生后数小时要多得多。但这种差异在两岁时开始逆转，女孩在语言上的情绪表达能力变得比男孩更强。而在四岁到六岁之间，小男孩们失去了面部表情表达能力。现在，四岁到六岁的男孩身上发生了什么？他们在学前班或小学里，正受到其他男孩的监督。基本上其他男孩在因为他们表达情绪而羞辱他们。
They're reinforcing the masculine code. So I theorize that boys who are socialized to conform to masculine neurons, particularly the one of restrictive emotionality, grow up to be men who are mildly a lexathymic. And I've done a number of studies to provide support for that and actually developed a treatment intervention, a manualized treatment, six sessions for psychologists working with men. It can be incorporated into the regular treatment to help them recover their ability to talk about their emotional life, which is essential to doing psychotherapy, essential. Even the most behavioral methods of psychotherapy, like exposure therapy, expect that the patient
他们在强化男子气概准则。因此我推论，那些被社会化以遵从男子气概规范的男孩，尤其是限制性情绪这一规范，长大后会成为有轻度述情障碍的男性。我做过许多研究来为之提供支持，并且实际上开发了一种治疗干预措施，一种手册化的治疗，即为与男性合作的心理学家提供的六次会谈。它可以被纳入常规治疗中，以帮助他们恢复谈论自己情感生活的能力，这对于进行心理治疗是必不可少的，绝对必不可少的。甚至像暴露疗法这样最依赖行为主义的心理治疗方法，也期望患者
is able to discern within himself how he's feeling. So it's something that when you're treating an elixotamic patient, a man, can be very helpful in terms of helping him gain and benefit from the therapy. So I understand that over the past year, you and your colleagues have been doing research on men's behavior and health during the COVID-19 pandemic. What have you found so far? If I can just back up from that question and say a few things,
能够在内心辨别出自己的感受。因此，当你治疗一个有述情障碍的患者——一个男性时，这在帮助他从治疗中获得收益方面会非常有帮助。所以我了解到，在过去的一年里，你和你的同事一直在研究新冠肺炎大流行期间男性的行为和健康。到目前为止你们发现了什么？如果我可以从那个问题退一步，说几句话的话，
you did mention men's lower longevity than women in the beginning. In addition, men have higher morbidity in most major categories of illness than women, and men have poorer health behaviors than women. And so men smoke more, drink more, take more risks, do not go to the doctors often, do not take medications as it prescribed. There are 30 controlled behaviors identified by a colleague in which men have poorer health habits than women. And obviously, you can make the linkages between the health habits and the morbidities and mortality. Now, in the COVID epidemic at the time we started the study, which is in 2020, men were getting more severe infections, that is,
你在开头确实提到了男性的寿命比女性短。此外，在大多数主要疾病类别中，男性的发病率都高于女性，男性的健康行为也比女性差。因此，男性的吸烟量更多、饮酒更多、承担更多风险、不常去看医生、不按处方服药。有一位同事指出了30种受控行为，在这些行为中，男性的健康习惯比女性差。显然，你可以在健康习惯与发病率和死亡率之间建立联系。现在，在我们开始研究的新冠疫情期间（即2020年），男性感染情况更为严重，也就是说，
more ICU admissions, and more dying to a greater extent than women. And there have been some biological factors that have been connected to that, particularly something concerning immunity and so forth. But there are also prevalent behavioral factors, and that's what we focus on being psychologists. And we wanted to see to what extent masculinity played a role in men's unwillingness to engage in mitigation measures to prevent their infection with COVID-19. And we did find, indeed, that adherence to what's called the playboy norm, that is the belief in, you know, casual sex with many women, that it transmitted the effect of their endorsement of traditional masculinity ideology on their actual engagement in Centers for Disease Control and Prevention
进入ICU的病例更多，死亡人数也比女性多得多。有一些生物学因素与此有关，特别是关于免疫力等方面的问题。但也存在普遍的行为因素，而这正是我们作为心理学家所关注的焦点。我们想要弄清楚，男子气概在多大程度上影响了男性不愿意采取缓解措施来防止自己感染新冠病毒。我们确实发现，对所谓的花花公子规范（playboy norm）的遵从——也就是说，相信与许多女性发生随意性交的信念——传递了他们对传统男子气概意识形态的认同对其在实际参与美国疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）
recommended practices for mitigating COVID-19. So masculinity is the culprit. Another factor we found, as you know, the COVID epidemic has been politicized to the hilt. And so the other factor is we found that holding conspiratorial attitudes about the pandemic also moderated that relationship between masculinity and adherence to CDC practices. That is, the more a man believed that COVID was a, you know, was a fraud and it was just designed to make President Trump look bad and all this other stuff. things along those lines, to that extent they were less willing to engage in mitigation practices. And that's coming out in APA's journal, Health Psychology, I believe. We'll be looking for that.
推荐的减轻新冠肺炎疫情的实践中的影响。所以男子气概是罪魁祸首。我们发现的另一个因素是，如你所知，新冠疫情已经被极度政治化。因此另一个因素是，我们发现持有关于这场大流行的阴谋论态度也会调节男子气概与对CDC实践的遵从之间的关系。也就是说，一个男性越是相信新冠肺炎是一场骗局，它仅仅旨在让特朗普总统难堪以及诸如此类的事情，
So just to change gears a little bit, and probably this would be the last question. In this past year, we've seen an uptick in the number of athletes who are talking about their health struggles, Naomi Osaka, Simone Biles, probably they're the most. most famous among these, but men are speaking up as well, including football and basketball players. Do you think that this reflects a broader change in men's willingness to talk about mental health and will it make some men more open to reaching out for help? Yeah, this has been going on for several decades, actually. Most recently, I live in Northeast Ohio and one of our basketball players.
事情沿着这些路线发展，他们在多大程度上就不愿意参与缓解疫情的实践。这似乎将在APA的期刊《健康心理学》（Health Psychology）上发表，我相信如此。我们会关注那一点的。所以只是稍微改变一下话题，这大概是最后一个问题了。在过去的一年里，我们看到越来越多的运动员开始谈论他们的健康挣扎，大阪直美（Naomi Osaka）、西蒙娜·拜尔斯（Simone Biles），她们可能是其中最著名的，但男性也在大声说出来，包括足球和篮球运动员。你认为这反映了男性在谈论心理健康方面意愿的更广泛转变吗？这会使一些男性更愿意寻求帮助吗？是的，实际上这已经持续了几十年了。最近，我住在俄亥俄州东北部，我们的一个篮球运动员。
Kevin Love had a panic attack during a basketball game and had to leave and go and to the locker room and later was quite open about it. And he also was very critical of masculinity in what he said. Basically, he said, you know, we were raised to never show, you know, any vulnerability. We're always supposed to be, you know, 100% on and ready for competition. And but, you know, we're human beings and we're made of flesh and blood, not steel and bolts. And I mean, I think this can have a very positive effect because among certain groups of men, athletes are almost revered, at least good athletes are, and to see major athletes coming out expressing their vulnerabilities, saying it's healthy to do so, saying they felt better after getting therapy,
凯文·乐福（Kevin Love）在篮球比赛中患上了恐慌发作，不得不离开并前往更衣室，后来对此相当坦诚。他在发言中对男子气概也持高度批判态度。基本上，他说，你知道，我们从小就被教育绝不表现出任何脆弱。我们应该永远处于百分之百启动状态，随时准备好参加比赛。但是，你知道，我们是有人有肉的生物，是由血肉组成的，而不是由钢铁和螺栓构成的。我的意思是，我认为这会产生非常积极的影响，因为在某些男性群体中，运动员几乎是备受尊崇的，至少优秀的运动员是如此，看到主要运动员挺身而出表达他们的脆弱，说这样做是健康的，说他们在接受治疗后感觉更好，
I think can help a lot. Do we have any evidence that it has helped? Studies like that haven't been done, that I'm aware of, but they should be. One last word. I know that's, I said that was the last question, but it occurs to me just for our listeners. if there are men out there who really want to deal with their feelings, who want to become, you know, less restricted in the way that they live, where and how can they find help? How can they find a therapist, say, who would understand this? Well, the National Register of Health Service Providers in Psychology has a service called Find a Psychologist. If you just go to the National Register, you know, I think it's national register.com. the find a psychologist is right on the front page, and you can find a licensed psychologist in your
我认为这可以提供很大帮助。我们有任何证据表明它有所帮助吗？据我所知，尚未进行过这样的研究，但应该进行。最后一句话。我知道，我说过那是最后一个问题，但对于我们的听众来说，我想到了这一点：如果有些男性真的想处理自己的感受，想要变得，你知道，在生活方式上受到的限制更少，他们可以在哪里以及如何寻求帮助呢？比方说，他们如何找到能理解这一点的治疗师？嗯，心理学国家健康服务提供者名册（National Register of Health Service Providers in Psychology）有一项名为“寻找心理学家”（Find a Psychologist）的服务。如果你去国家名册，你知道，我认为是national register.com，“寻找心理学家”就在首页上，你可以找到一位有执照的心理学家
local area, and I think most psychologists, you know, would be able to help such a potential client deal with the things that are bothering them. But beyond going to a therapist, I would say to men who might be listening, who might have some of these issues, you know, we have to brave the shame. We were made to feel ashamed of ourselves for not being fully masculine, and that was nonsense. If you're married, if you have children, you have to learn how to open up your heart to your family, to really let them in, to take the barriers down. You can do it. It's not easy. You will feel bad about it. You might feel ashamed of yourself. But honestly, those lessons you learn as a child are not valid. And a better approach is to have an open heart and an open mind and to freely
本地的资源，我想大多数心理学家都知道如何帮助这样潜在的客户应对困扰他们的事情。但除了去看心理医生之外，我想对可能正在收听节目、可能遇到其中一些问题的男性说，我们必须勇敢地面对羞耻感。我们曾因为自己不够具有男子气概而感到羞耻，那是无稽之谈。如果你已婚，如果你有孩子，你必须学会如何向你的家人敞开心扉，真正让他们走进来，放下防备。你能做到这一点。这并不容易。你会为此感到不好受。你可能会为自己感到羞耻。但老实说，你小时候学到的那些教训是无效的。更好的方法是保持一颗开放的心和开明的思想，并自由地
express your emotions to the people you care about. Dr. Levant, I want to thank you not just for joining us today, but for this very important work that you've been doing for so many years. I personally appreciate it. And I'm sure many of our listeners do as well. Thank you. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeckycology.org.combeckycology. or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
向你在乎的人表达你的情绪。Levant博士，我不仅要感谢你今天能来到节目中，还要感谢你多年来一直在从事这项非常重要的工作。我个人对此非常感激。我相信我们的许多听众也是如此。谢谢你。谢谢。你可以在 www.combeckycology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何你喜欢的播客平台上找到《心理学聊天》往期的节目。请给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学聊天》由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的音响编辑是Chris Condyenne。谢谢收听。我是Kim Mills，代表美国心理协会。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。